Real world data is a relatively new term
encompassing data derived from a number of sources shown
here that affect clinical outcomes in
a heterogeneous patient population in real world settings.
Earlier in his interview,
John Duke use the term observational data and
it is essentially a synonym for real world data.
We also refer to this kind of data in our discussions of public and population health.
So, their impact goes far beyond individual patient care.
The hope is that analysis of this
richer and broader data set will generate meaningful insights into
unmet needs and interventional strategies with
greater clinical and economic impact on patients and health care systems.
There are of course as shown here new challenges
introduced when the range and scope of data sources expands.
Understand the potential value of real world data.
I suggest you read a short but interesting and insightful article by
a trio of researchers at Harvard's Center for biomedical informatics.
This diagram from it
organizes potential health data sets along different dimensions of bigness.
The authors point out that while electronic health records provide depth by including
multiple sources of data such as images and
clinical notes about individual patient encounters,
claims data provide longitudinally,
a less clinically detail but more continuous view of
a patient's medical history over an extended time period.
Medical data may be episodic and
incomplete if a patient receives care from multiple providers.
Typically, there's only one payer for a time period so that payers
claims from within that period should be a more complete record of care delivered.
On the other hand,
claims data lacks clinical detail.
A request for payment for a lab test order would be in a claim
but the results would not be included as they usually are in any H.R.
As a result, the authors of this paper say,
"linking data adds value when they help fill in the gaps.
With this in mind, it becomes easier to see how nontraditional sources of
biomedical data outside of the healthcare system fit into the picture.
Social media, credit card purchases,
census records and numerous other types of data despite varying degrees of quality,
can help assemble a holistic view of a patient and in particular
shed light on social and environmental factors that may be influencing them."